presenting officer this is a really
serious situation and we must respond
accordingly i therefore want to strongly
underline the advice i gave on tuesday
please reduce your contact with people
from households other than your own as
much as you possibly can for now please
stay at home much more than you normally
would and as much as is feasible
right now the risk of getting covered
from interactions with others is high
and it is rising so ask yourself before
doing anything you might have planned
over the coming days is it as safe as it
needs to be and is it vital enough to
you to justify that risk i suspect what
is most important to most of us over the
next couple of weeks is having time with
our families at christmas
every interaction we have before then
increases the risk of us getting covered
and so possibly losing that more
generally i suspect what matters most to
us and i know this is strongly my view
is protecting children's education so by
acting to reduce community transmission
we will also be helping keep schools
open and open safely deciding officer
given what i am being advised about the
risk omicron poses to health and the
economy i would not be fulfilling my
duty if i failed to give this advice i
would not be acting in good conscience
however i am acutely aware of and deeply
concerned about the considerable impact
of this advice on businesses although
let me repeat businesses will also
suffer if we don't act to slow the virus
the fact is business now needs the type
and scale of financial support that was
available earlier in the pandemic
however there are simply no mechanisms
available to the devolved
administrations to trigger the scale of
finance needed to support such schemes
we need the uk government to act
urgently and in the same way some other
countries are already doing
i made this point again at a cobra
meeting yesterday chaired by michael
gove and attended by the chief secretary
to the treasury but this now needs the
urgent engagement of the prime minister
and the chancellor we must not sleepwalk
into an emergency that for both health
and business will be much greater as a
result of inaction than it will be if we
act firmly and strongly now i've
therefore written to the prime minister
this morning appealing to him to put the
necessary support schemes in place such
as the urgency i've asked to speak to
him directly later today exciting
officer none of us want to be in this
position but omicron presents a renewed
and very real challenge for the whole
world the world health organization
could not be clearer about that
once again the duty to protect the nhs
lives and livelihoods must be uppermost
in our minds and it must drive our
actions all of us governments and
citizens must do what is required i'm
asking everybody across the country
please play your part again by following
the advice we are giving thank you